e tu con cosa si vuole affittare in
questo li passato macellaio cattivo
vuole partiamo mente vuole aspettarci lo
vede c'e dietro di noi ancorate che
quindi queste ski promo dovrebbe
scappare da lui e dalle sue affettatrici
lasciate stamina mi piaceva affatto
provatele se non mi piace 35 secondi 543
dove è
tenuta oggi siete riusciti e ora
mettetevi comodi preti pop corn e
iniziavo subito quest'anno verte plumbeo
vitale quante volte si straccerà al
mediano di indovinare mi importante
avere un caso su qualche coltello ma 20
che parla sta urlando ok
se non mi seguite al corato integra
mandati a seguirmi come anita stories
lui piace mi odi o mi ami aventi natura
un quella che grande dove dietro non mi
vede anche farina in testa guarda
tu dove sei finito qui dietro di te mi
sono già sfracellato è
niente in questa stanza devi stare
attento a quel gas refrigerante tipo un
freezer esatto e locali e affettare
personale mette in pdl soprattutto
perché si muore con facilitarli hamsik
c'è passato che sei dietro di te mi sono
appena strage ma meno male che ti vorrei
arriva con facilità il ragazzo a passata
e corri tale se la farà certo
ma salviamo
perfetto dai attento a non cadere
quella nobile idea sembra uno dei denti
eccolo lì sfracellato fi puoi farcela si
è così siamo arrivati
si sono salvati di ghiaccio
speriamo alla fine delle schede di non
finire nella bocca del macellaio no hay
group
vediamo se ce la fa si
mette davanti a un occhio solo questo
bisogna andare forse bisogna saltare
sopra cosa che cosa così
o no bisognava evitarle fra cercati
tutto ok allora bisogna inter e torino
anche tu abbiamo stimato che allora
posso restare super attenti magari
saltando ok cose potevano andare sì il
trucco quando si scivola così saltare
talenti ci siamo quasi
ce l'ho fatta ai veri sono quinti minuto
timido cielo per farcela
andiamo e cosa succede nelle scale
tutto questo fino adesso
c'è ancora questo gatto blu
violentamento evita queste strisce
c'è scritto che non possiamo entrare
solo il personale utilizzate noi siamo
autoritario no c'è quello di mare delle
partite guarda aiuto agli dove dobbiamo
salire sulla salsiccia poveri di questi
sono gli altri giocatori che non ce
l'hanno
vai piano è abbastanza facile fin qui
dai cioè accesso al lato quello che si
sfrangia tiratissimo e sulla salsiccia
dicevo
è
conclusa si vuole affettare con come si
chiamano le mannaie delle asce all
ok
se n'è fatta quasi
turati 6 affettando ancora notte ero
riuscito a passare
a però
credo più piano ok abbiamo salvato il
tempo attento non toccare niente
quale sarà la strada giusta equa sì
siamo in un garage possono guidare il
muletto muletto questa qui si chiama
muletto il trattorino
ok torna in quanto riguarda
i doni radioattivi e io che non tocchi
la parte verde questo verde radioattivo
credo sia proprio l'ideale sono riuscito
a passare che cos'è la testa devo
prenderla sai che non lo so
sembra già ok però tocca prévert la lupa
audio questo bari il fratello sempre
ha fatto distruggere perché tutti devono
lavorare vitale devo superare evitare
devo arrivare a prendere il badge prima
di vitale non sei riuscito a passare
come ho fatto
ecco vitale vediamo
cosa sono un tritacarne penso quindi
stai molto attento a non cadere dentro
il primo aspetto qui c'è anche una saga
siamo stati tritati
affettati
la cgt ma allora secondo me ha forse ho
capito come fare lì ma non ci sia una
mucca poverina
ma tutti 6 spreca al lato di nuovi detto
che avevi capito come fare avevo già
fatta come ho fatto a bloccarla non
bloccata e perché si è bloccata a
noi non riporti d'oro quindi ogni tanto
si blocca se dobbiamo aspettare che si
blocchi
io sono passato che bloccando anch'io ho
sorpassato
fa vitale mi ha superato non è giusto a
vedere le persone ma noi ovviamente se
andremo lo stesso vediamo come perfetta
o abbiamo sempre quadri del mare ad un
fiume radioattivo condivido niente
perché invece non cadere giù di tono
delle mucche troppo ma dobbiamo
liberarla dobbiamo provare a sognare
non ho però possiamo saltare sopra
questi laser
perché non riesco a liberarla muoverli
da dovrei disattivare il laser per
liberarla faccia più avanti e qui sono
buche per sé dopo riusciremo a liberarle
è anche youtube ho capito bisogna
saltare sulla mucca per riuscire a
contare e qua invece devi salire quassù
paglia sale sulla bocca grazie mucca
riusciva
no ok ho capito devi sempre stalin su
qualcosa per superare i laser quindi se
non sulla mucca allora sulla ciotola ok
[Musica]
perché l'ultimo laser è così difficile
allora basta prendere un po di zisis
solo prendere un po più di rincorsa che
provo
ma quello programma ma li
proviamo a salvare anche lei attento a
non perdere l'equilibrio ok poi è molto
difficile temi aiutare davvero o no
questa parte perde da sei giorni è così
erano dietro di te e coraggio vitale che
[Musica]
mi guarda con gli occhi
forse proviamo dove volevi saltare pure
di prendere la scorciatoia
non ha funzionato
è difficile perché oltre a dover andare
piano e in equilibrio qua sopra bisogna
anche saltare insomma posti
del nuovo nell'appello voto non ci credo
abitare quasi arrivato non posso
operarmi devo raggiungerlo con l'ultimo
salto ok ciao vitale laggiù nella lingua
della mucca round di tre dentro alla
bocca infatti se ti aspetto perché poi
mi sa che dovrò pur uscire dal prato
quella parte che non riuscivo a superare
contro in corsa salto giusto in tempo
brava aiuto quando di andare proprio
così visto che
questa è l'ultima
salviamo e andiamo su realizzati
entriamo
vediamo cosa ha mangiato la bocca e
allora qui siamo una cosa la lingua
strana è vista che cadremo adesso
è il malo buca mangiato quelle cose là
di alcune donne ragazzi ma poi c'è una
mela verde una bella rossa una carota un
bidone radioattivo perché fa sempre bene
ogni tanto un vino nel reduci ma
un'altra mela rossa ti voglio
siamo
guardati male o
si ok ho capito bisogna andare una
giocata male ha fatto sì che la
rete
non possiamo dire la strada ma io ma noi
prima tu
no ok forse ho capito è per forza questa
tempo e sarà questa centrale no è
centrale no è quella sinistra che mister
a quel no
ricordiamoci solo a destra
no di tre poi sinistra di nuovo ok
sarà per forza quella centrale no non ci
credo che oggi proviamo questa volta
sappiamo tutto poi destra mister no era
sinistra punto sinistra quale sarà
dentro sinistro proviamo destra ei e la
destra e la sinistra e poi destra ea
volte vitale se ne dimentica ma come
faccio
io
avevo giurato forza bisognerà dire qua
nelle otto le vertebre non so cosa siano
ha detto
ogni volta che vitale ride si procederà
anche lui devi prendere bene la misura
del salto c'è quasi fatta così si supera
un italia
non lo devo fare dire che si può buttare
altrimenti mi spiace mi ha superato
allora siamo figli e prima io queste
skipper ti volevo già stati la vita che
siamo io che sono in una parte marrone
la tua parte preferita
a qualcosa mi dice che questa era
difficile
no so lo so io li odio per
saltare un tempo non ce la faccio mai no
ho un'idea proprio con la tecnica di
saltare in continuazione no ci vuole
ci vuole il ritmo giusto
ma già lo so che muore molti di marina
un sacco di muovere
solo questa parte salto note e
anch'io e concentrazione questa volta ce
la faccio
e meglio che non dico niente
d'ora in poi non dirò niente
assolutamente niente vediamo se funziona
no no no funziona anche lo stile di euro
vicinissimo bene prepara la tenda da
campeggio e preparati a vivere qua e
sorpassano non ci credo eccome
come hai fatto che sono tutto no dimmi
come impatto sicuramente entrato qualche
trucchetto ma ora bisogna solo stare
attenti al tema nono anch'io pensavo di
essere stato ancora la testa sfracellata
invece no
ci sono questi ci sono trasferite nel 19
perduranti aspetta forse non si
ma basta ora tema però no
c'era infatti a noi ragazzi lo potete
capire dono bordo almeno 45 volte ma
finalmente si era fatta anche vitale
stavo prendendo le sue
maturità ci vediamo ti aspetto perché
che cosa quelli reali ci è piaciuto un
sacco per farlo questo invece
no devi salire su
dobbiamo salire su questa lampada qui
sospese
pericoloso in alto si è come ce l'ho
fatta dovuto presentarmi qui siete non
possiamo entrare male ovviamente come
sempre entreremo
questo come funziona sempre tipo tetris
ma sì rotolato giù
se colpisci la parte gialla si
accanì giu di burro scivolo di bisogno
per nuovo a camminare ma poi ad esaltare
anche puoi anche saltare nelle
particelle vediamo veri più
attento non simulare sarà
divertentissimo papa salviamo un mare di
sangue non solo ma indiano non cadere
giù
[Musica]
tutto
ora tutti stranamente
[Musica]
forse l'ultimo buttarci
sta rotolando
non sto cavando cose se c'è proprio
corpo
nuovo e non rotolo più non lo so perché
di camminare dopo un po forse è meglio
così almeno mi sfrecciava di nuovo o no
e ma dove si sono sfracellato pure io ho
preso mai a letto non dobbiamo cadere
sotto no ma è molto facile che aveva
migliore pensiamo bene da che parte
santo
santa dalla testa e così se sì ho visto
e posso toccare le parti verdi per
fortuna
da evitare
sono corso dietro
[Musica]
e sul primo maialetto dai puoi farcela
forte ci sono quattro
attori presso penso che avevo finito
siamo fuori
mettiamo
di oggi devo arrendermi
ehi facciamo chi arriva prima al badge
ok
battaglia è corrotto i carri eccolo il
badge l'azzurro vedete siamo stati prima
io primo vitale perché sono stati eletti
perché personale
ei togliti non mi sarà niente eccolo
eccolo
lui c'era
abbiamo preso il peggio
wired graffiata
zero per mi piace
ops mi è caduto il segreto
di cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video il campo su quella che preferite